not to say San Francisco wasn't a blast
so fun but I think a lot of people
keeping off in fentanyl in Portland
yeah yeah we went to Portland like uh
when we were touring with bam oh so
gnarly dude it was like yeah because
I've been to Portland we've been to
Portland several times and it was so
[__] bad this time that like they
were locking the doors to the stores you
couldn't walk either people were smoking
tin foil heroin almost everywhere in the
open just on the sidewalk people with
the the lighters under the tin foil and
shooting up like just foil everywhere
all over the ground yeah stores closed
and like you have to knock on it I mean
dude I remember the first time I saw a
foil on the ground I was like damn
they'd be cooking a lot out here I
didn't know it was for drugs you know so
I was like a lot of leftovers a lot of
meal prepping in Portland you know well
like we're pulling over to park to go
into a store and you get out and there's
a guy just lighting up a foil
but that's the thing that decriminalized
yeah they can't get in trouble so
they're not nothing's wrong that's crazy
I think about the times where I grew up
in camera and I got a ticket for riding
a skateboard without a helmet yeah and
now there's guys just smoking PCP just
in front of a safe way you know how does
that check out
betterhelp.com if you've been thinking
about trying therapy I urge you to
follow that instinct and follow it right
to betterhelp.com
yeah dude